le propongo que analicemos las
conclusiones de este congreso por partes
primero en términos de liderazgo de chip
por un lado porque ha sacado al Premier
League One yang del comité central
Bueno muy buenos días para todos
Muchísimas gracias por la invitación Yo
pienso que esto hace parte precisamente
del cambio en rejuvenecimiento que
quiere el presidente para garantizar
precisamente un liderazgo dentro del
partido pienso que ahí hay varios temas
entre ellos uno es el envejecimiento
precisamente de parte del comité central
otro punto puede ser ya los temas de
jubilación Entonces en ese aspecto es
importante que el presidente tenga
precisamente como como una línea
inquebrantable del camino del desarrollo
político el socialismo y por eso se
piensa que él hace estos cambios para
garantizar Obviamente el funcionamiento
y el desempeño del papel del partido
como tal dentro de estas políticas que
él quiere a futuro y Alex abordemos
ahora los cambios en el militar y de
unidad nacional Como por ejemplo la
oposición explícita a la independencia
de Taiwán en la constitución del partido
en qué medida las conclusiones de este
congreso significan un cambio o sigue en
una línea más bien continuista
Bueno yo pienso que el presidente ha
hecho algunos cambios específicamente en
este último congreso donde el reitera
que es partidario de la unidad
específicamente de la reunificación
pacífica con Taiwán pero que él estaría
dispuesto a utilizar el uso de la fuerza
él tiene como ejemplo pues lo que ha
sucedido entre Ucrania y Rusia y no
quiere cometer esos errores y él dice
que efectivamente Esto hace parte de que
se tiene que resolver de una forma
pacífica entonces lo que estamos viendo
Es que él busca que el pueblo chino sea
el que tome la decisión y no haya
injerencia internacional hay que esperar
que va a pasar en los próximos meses ya
sabiendo que él va a ser reelegido
Entonces se va a revisar como esa
política militar va a cambiar pero él
mantiene es la reunificación como tal
con Taiwán y ahora un paréntesis uno de
los episodios más comentados de la
sesión de hoy ha sido cuando fuerzas de
seguridad sacaron de la sala al
expresidente huschenta se especula entre
cuestiones de salud del ex mandatario y
el que podría ser un acto inédito de
purga pública lo posible
Yo pienso que es más un tema de purga
pública porque son contradictores
personas que de pronto no están a favor
de algunas medidas del presidente
Entonces yo creo que esa escena marca un
poco netamente lo que fue ese congreso
cierto el cambio vuelvo a reitero el
cambio de de rejuvenecer este partido y
algunas políticas Que obviamente el
presidente quiere implementar de su
partido entonces
miraremos a ver también cómo sucede esto
desde de mañana cuando se haga la
lección como tal y efectivamente Pues
para el mundo hay un claro mensaje de la
postura como tal del presidente ante sus
decisiones políticas sociales militares
y Alex cerremos en términos económicos
Cuáles son los objetivos de China para
el futuro por un lado respecto al nivel
de vida de su población y por otro
respecto a su papel de potencia global y
más particularmente puede china mantener
la política de Cero covid y aspirar al
mismo tiempo al crecimiento económico
Yo pienso que el presidente ha sido
claro su política de rejuvenecimiento
comercial que darle vida al tema rural
es una economía milenaria o es una
civilización entre la cual se ha
desarrollado permanentemente Así que la
propuesta de él es que para el 2030 2035
china debe ser la potencia mundial en el
mercado Por eso Abre ha abierto los
espacios en relaciones internacionales
permite que haya una una Liberación una
una libertad económica cierto y eso va a
permitir también que china se consolide
en unos años Dentro de este marco
digamos comercial aludiendo
efectivamente que debe haber una
trazabilidad en cuanto lo que es el
manejo de la ciencia la tecnología y la
capacitación en el ámbito rural